-Welcome to "The Tonight Show
At Home Edition," everybody.
Thank you so much
for being here.
It is Wednesday!
Oh, yeah, man.
[ Snapping fingers ]
That's what I'm talkin' about.
Actually, it's almost
Thursday, basically.
So it's Thursday, kind of.
You gettin' that vibe?
You gettin' that vibe from me?
Cool, cool, cool.
Alright, let's get
to some news here, everybody!
Tomorrow, President Trump
will be visiting
a Ford plant in Michigan
that requires face masks,
but Trump said he's not sure
if he'll wear one.
Trump actually loves Ford,
especially 'cause the "F"
in the logo
sort of looks like his hair.
I think Trump might be
a little disappointed
when he gets
to the Ford factory
'cause, once he walks in,
he's gonna be like,
"When I asked to see
the new models,
this is not what I meant."
Well, guys,
the election is coming up
and everyone's debating
mail-in voting.
Republicans are worried
old people
will be confused
by a new system,
while Democrats are worried
young people
won't know how
to mail a letter.
Check this out -- I saw
that the NFL is testing helmets
that have an N95 face mask
built into them.
Yeah. And, if that works,
football will be
completely safe.
People are talking about this --
last night, in Chicago,
the Willis Tower lost power
and it looked
like it had a face.
Take a look.
That tower looks like it's got
a serious case
of resting building face.
That looks like every LEGO,
hiding in the dark,
[ Laughing ]
waiting for me to step on it.
Some TV news --
Kristen Cavallari announced
that she is ending her reality
show "Very Cavallari."
It's very sad. Earlier today
on the E! network,
the exclamation point was
changed to a somber period.
This went viral this week --
apparently, Chuck E. Cheese
realized that nobody was
ordering their pizza as takeout,
so they changed their name
on delivery apps
to Pasqually's Pizza,
after a member
of their robotic band.
I guess there's a member
called Pasqually,
so, Pasqually's Pizza.
They basically tried
to trick people
into ordering Chuck E. Cheese.
Well, today we found out
they're not the only ones.
Check out this commercial
I just saw.
-[ French accent ]
Stop searching for the next
culinary revelation
[ French tune plays ]
and experience ze excellence,
taste the magnificence,
indulge in the elegance
at Grimace's Bistro,
available on delivery apps
or le drive-through.
-Looks pretty good, actually.
I just saw that, for the summer,
Absolut unveiled
the new line
of ready-to-drink vodka sodas.
'Cause that was always
the problem with vodka sodas --
they took way
too much time to make.
You gotta put the vodka
and the soda...
Sometimes you do the soda,
instead of the vodka.
You do the vodka and the soda.
Soda, the vodka, soda.
You do the soda.
This is crazy --
a grocery store in Missouri
had apparently replaced
all the items in their salad bar
[ Laughing ]
with tiny liquor bottles.
Take a look at this.
The hard part was picking up
the liquor bottles
with the salad tongs.
They also renamed
the sneeze guard
to the puke roof.
[ Chuckle ]
Check this out --
I saw that the Belmont Stakes
is now scheduled
to take place
before the Kentucky Derby.
Racing fans were outraged,
while the horses continue
to have no idea what's going on.
Guys, that's our monologue,
right there.
We have a awesome show tonight!
Anthony Anderson is here
[ Clap ] tonight!
Michelle Dockery is here;
and, of course,
we have great, great music
from Gary Clark Jr.
Hey, everyone. It's Wednesday,
which means it's time
for "What Are You Doing
Wednesday."
-♪ What are you doin'? ♪
♪ It's Wednesday ♪
♪ What are you doin'? ♪
♪♪
-These are videos
that I've seen online
that you guys are all making
'cause we're all inside
and doing something,
trying to be creative.
I think these are my favorite
videos I've seen this week,
so, thank you.
Keep making these videos
and I'll find them.
This first one is from Maryland.
It's a restaurant
that thought of a fun way
for diners to socially distance.
Check it out.
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
It's all fun and games
until Barb gets bumped
into the lake.
This next one is from @kpakster.
They were bored
during quarantine,
so he and a friend
made up a game
with a broken Walgreens sign.
[ Laughing ]
Check this out.
-Walg.
-Greens.
Greens.
-Walg.
-Greens.
-Greens. Greens.
-Walg.
-Greens.
They did that for eight hours.
This next one's
from Kate Sibbick.
She invented a game to keep
both her and her kids busy.
Check this out.
[ Video game music ]
[ Bell rings ]
[ Toy squeaking ]
♪♪
Ah, I like that one
little, tiny mole.
There was like a bonus mole
that got in there.
Cute. That was great.
Alright.
Now, get out and let your --
get your dad under there
and get me a real hammer.
This last one is
@ashleycacioppo's dad
got a little too immersed
in his virtual reality
plank experience.
Watch this.
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, oh, he did!
[ Crash ]
-Oh, my!
-[ Laughing ]
Oh! Oh!
Oh, my God.
"Mom!
Mom, the TV broke Dad!"
There you go, everybody.
That is
"What Are You Doing Wednesday."